another prominent Democrat announces his
exit from Congress
unable to surmount a storm of sexual
misconduct a gala gay shion's against
him senator al franken taking the floor
of his chamber earlier exactly three
weeks after the first accusations
surfaced from radio host Lee aunt Whedon
he began with this a couple months ago I
felt that we had entered an important
moment in the history of this country
we were finally beginning to listen to
women about the ways in which men's
actions affect them then the
conversation turned to me some of the
allegations against me are simply not
true others I remember very differently
I know there's been a very different
picture of me painted over the last few
weeks but I know who I really am
although Franken disputes most of the
allegations he ultimately cave to
pressure to step down in the coming
weeks I will be resigning as a member of
the United States Senate this decision
is not about me it's about the people of
Minnesota this has been a tough few
weeks for me but I am a very very lucky
man I have a beautiful healthy family
that I love and that loves me very much
I'm going to be just fine
you know what I didn't hear him say Dana
I'm gonna say like resigning this way
means never having to say you're sorry
but I actually think that he doesn't
truly believe he did anything wrong
doesn't and also you know he's watched
other people deny allegations and be
just fine and I think he probably
thought he could weather the storm but
there were additional anonymous accusers
that were coming forward and I think
that basically the Democrats are saying
you are no longer welcome here and
you're going to be sitting alone in the
Senate dining room but no one's going to
talk to you we're gonna you're dead to
us we're gonna walk I am curious about
the decision to resign in the coming
weeks what do you think that's about I'm
not
I heard a theory it's a theory do can I
say it yes okay I told Greg in the green
room but this is not my theory that he's
a space alien a shape-shifting lizard
hmm close all right here was somebody's
theory okay that he said I'm gonna
resign in the coming weeks because he is
waiting to see what will happen in the
Alabama special and then if Roy Mar does
win and is going to be seated then and
then he could reversed his decision and
not resign that's just a theory I
actually kind of agree with the theory
gutfeld I think he's leaving a crack in
the door this big because he wants to
see how this plays out because you know
from the beginning of this this guy did
not want to lose the suit yeah well my
mom always said you grab a seat you lose
a seat look she was why it's my favorite
part of his speech by the way I don't
even think Frank and believes Franken
getting him out of the Senate will
require dentistry he said that he won
that election by 312 votes when he beat
Norm Coleman he was talking about that
so imagine if all of these stories which
happened before he ran had come out then
he would not be in the Senate so the
fact is instead of being sad he should
be thanking his lucky stars that he got
what eight years in the Senate he got
eight years in the Senate he got he was
not supposed to win if those stories had
come out he would not be standing there
so the he should have been thanking
these women for not saying anything
because yeah I mean look this is how
long let's and I love how you know guys
so now that there's that other part
where he goes after Trump and more but
innocent mentioned Phil Clinton or his
enabler Hilary so I'm just wondering is
this a new party is this what 20 years
ago this party ignored and played down
Bill Clinton's sexual excesses and they
nominated a woman who shamed the victims
right so ornate is this a new leaf for
them are they changing their colors I
don't know they're trying to turn over a
new leaf and is it that's the that's the
that's the game that they're playing
because they're trying to create a
contrast between the Democrats and the
Republicans that's why they're doing
this are you gonna say that they've
driven out that they've drawn this red
line right will anybody be able to cross
it there are reports that there are up
to 40 members of Congress
we're looking at possible stories along
I don't know what they're gonna say but
possible 14 people that could be some
Republicans and Democrats both the
Democrats hold that red line and it'll
probably happen on a Friday Greg
mentioned something that he the senator
had said about more and Trump let's
listen and have Keiji react okay I of
all people am aware that there is some
irony in the fact that I am leaving
while a man who has bragged on tape
about his history of sexual assault sits
in the Oval Office and a man who has
repeatedly preyed on young girls
campaigns for the Senate whether with
the full support of his party the
president addressed the comments back
during the campaign we feel strongly
that the people of this country also
addressed that when they elected Donald
Trump to be President and I've addressed
that several times from here and don't
have anything new to add so it looks
like the White House is saying can
really let the voters decide well
basically that was a message from Sarah
Sanders saying look you know this was
something that was vetted that was
brought out during the campaign that the
people the United States had the
opportunity to think about it evaluate
it determine the the strength of it and
how it should play an impact on their
decision of who to choose for
commander-in-chief so they made the
decision so she's saying there you go
there was nothing hidden it's not like
it came out after he became President of
the United States and quite frankly Al
Franken is lucky because as Greg said he
this could have come out earlier he was
he got to be you know in government and
work for the people and have this
position for quite a long period of time
before this information even came out
and I don't know why he's taking cheap
shots at the president I would be more
impressed if he said sorry for his
conduct and actions instead of trying to
flip the script and appoint the finger
at someone else instead of looking into
his own conscience and behavior and
making this a more of a teachable moment
of ownership not only for himself but
his family but for other members of
Congress as well respond to that one
what do you think I mean he really
whiffed when it came to a nice clean
classy
nation oh no I thought he was extremely
classy and he didn't even believe the
women let me finish well so he said it's
the worst day of his life and I don't
think you're a human being unless you
understand that that man was at the
pinnacle of success in terms of his
political life he said it came he came
to politics late in life but he worked
very hard and he worked in the tradition
of you may not know this name but Paul
Wellstone eirick who was a terrific
senator from Minnesota very much a
progressive you know kind of you know
farm laborer Democrat type of persona
that fits into Minnesota and an Al
Franken had to strive to get beyond the
image that he was just a comic and to be
dismissed as a political neophyte and he
did so and he is a very popular senator
both in Minnesota and nationally so much
so the people were talking about Al
Franken running for president so now you
come to a day when all of this goes to
tatters and his allies I mean people
like Kirsten Gillibrand patty Murray are
leading the fight to toss him overboard
I don't see how you can say that this
wasn't bitter and sad day he calls it
the worst day of his life but let me go
on or since it happened on this day no
well I think for him I'm just saying for
him I think it's pretty sad and I feel
for him I'm so sorry that this has
happened but I will say this that I find
myself in an odd situation where I agree
with people like Laura Ingraham and Sean
Hannity they to think that this is
Democrats turning on one of their own
and throwing them overboard for
political purposes that they will then
be better positioned in terms of
confronting charges against Roy Moore
especially if he's elected and there's
there's attempts to have him thrown out
as well as to continue the challenge
against President Trump and the charges
that he has standing to this day against
him in terms of women who say that he
acted in a vulgar manner with them can I
can I respond to one cuz I agree I do
think this is Astrid this is a strategic
move on their part what they're trying
to do I keep hearing the phrase partisan
divide over sexual harassment so by
doing this they're calling they're
basically saying we're not the
Republicans so I think this I think both
sides can be right I actually do feel
bad for Al Franken
but I also feel that he is lying because
I know for a fact he's lying because I
know but that's not the point the point
is what is he lying about Greg so is he
lying about tongue down woman's
throughout I don't look he said that
woman said that he tried the wet kisser
but that's one jet generally what we're
talking about more than one is groping
right on while pictures are being taken
hmm I think that's a whole lot different
than what we're talking about with Roy
Moore or even president okay but I just
think I just think at this moment where
something is going on in the country man
I agree and also I you know he said his
his other strong defense was what he did
is what you're saying is nothing as
serious as allegations directed at other
people I actually agree we have an
indiscriminate leveling of accusations
on malucia's which all now all
accusations are equal and we're gonna
have to we're gonna have to deal with
that at some point rather than letting
the court of public opinion and then
media indiscriminately decide that all
of these things are equal I think that
you know what he did before he became a
senator was his flaw I mean this he
thought that this was funny and it does
it and when it all came out it should
have come out before well but you know
the thing is it didn't happen while he
was a senator which is something we're
talking about right with many other
people that's what he that's yeah even
the allegations are prior to his tenure
as a senator but what strikes me time
and again is right now we are in the
country and I appreciate the fact that
you spoke to me honestly because I think
there's so much politics at play in this
so and one level we're talking about we
need to deal with the issue of sexual
harassment and intimidation of women and
women being silenced and afraid to speak
but on another level we're talking
politics here we're just talking about
Al Franken Roy Moore John Conyers it's
gonna go on and on because both sides
see some advantage in this